another vaccine has now been approved
for use
in the uk let's bring in skies
millennium selinovich who's in the
newsroom for us this afternoon
and tell us what it is milena yeah it's
yet another tool
in the fight against curvy the jansen
vaccine
manufactured by johnson and johnson has
just been approved by the uk
regulator it is found to have been
highly effective in preventing
disease overall up to 67 percent
effective in preventing covet-19
infections
it is also very efficient when it comes
to preventing severe disease that goes
up to 85
in preventing people from getting quite
badly ill
and admit it to hospital what's
particularly good about it is that like
the astrazeneca vaccine
it can be stored at fridge temperatures
from between two
and eight degrees celsius and easily
transported that makes it quite good for
use in
care homes those types of settings and
we also know
that the uk has ordered 20 million doses
of this vaccine
it will be available later on in the
year
in all four nations